[Music]
so i thought the uh epstein galle
maxwell trial would be the next oj trial
of the century-style trial but obviously
this johnny depp amber heard trial is
the real child i'm glad they let cameras
in court for them yeah hey
how about a round of applause for
captain jack
[Applause]
johnny depp when the
jack when the news first came out um
and those the whole expose you know that
amber did
um
do you guys remember that and like how
johnny just let like he just
didn't get any jobs just based off of
her
accusations alone he lost so many things
he got cut from uh the secrets of
dumbledore movie yeah yeah which by the
way perhaps a career blessing
really
dude everyone's hating on that movie big
time i heard it got like a [ __ ] zero
out of ten is that when dumbledore
has a
gay orgy no it's not that one that's
online important well no the secret's a
dumbledore right it's [ __ ] door so
dumbledore's gay but they edit it for
china
because you know hollywood loves uh the
gay community except for like when
they're trying to sell something to
china and then they're like hey oh [ __ ]
you guys who cares
it's the best
so cynical incorporated
ezra miller is still casted in there
oh yeah much more crazy whale non people
but at least ezra will wail on anybody
men women children
anyway
one of the funny things about this uh
amber heard uh john depth trial though
not many one of a million yeah elon musk
and james franco won't testify at the
trial actually oh yeah anybody familiar
with their connection to amber heard so
they were bolder right
oh that's better well better foot yeah
after before well the funny thing is
when uh when amber heard and johnny depp
had officially quote-unquote divorce but
they were still living together when
johnny depp was out of the house elon
musk would come over oh objection
hearsay
overruled
waiting for that but you just hit it so
right on the head
and dancers are funny sometimes it's not
clear exactly what uh franco's
relationship
is um
let me see frank was expected to test
five blah blah blah
oh franco's link was to uh johnny depp's
libel suit in 2020 against uh the sun
and the must
what is franco's don't they also have a
video of her in the elevator with him
right it was like two days after
james franco ah yeah it was james franco
had come over to the house one time and
that he had realized or noticed that
amber heard had like bruises on her face
or something like that
so then that's how he was linked to it
because he was like what happened and
then from there there was uh the
possibility of him testifying in the
case and then also bringing elon musk to
the case as well but both of them are
denying anything and not wanting to
testify well james franco was like well
i know i didn't do that so what the [ __ ]
is going
yeah he's like somebody beat her up i
what
on
saw what's going on with elon like
having bruises on his face yeah i saw
that too whoa from amber heard well they
were walking hand in hand but and he had
a little bit of redness on his face
right yeah wow i saw it like the other
day i don't know how damn she beating up
all her dudes huh that's amazing
but she's just also
like
aquaman you guys saw the first one yeah
uh no parts of it
absolutely terrible in it
and then you see it in this with her
acting hired for acting no i don't think
either because well she got the role
from johnny though didn't well he says
he said yeah here's how do you think she
got the role oh johnny said that yeah
john said how do you think you guys
don't think she's a talented woman and
she could get any role that she wants
from her skills like in her boobs and
her hard work
she actually dare you is she actually a
bad actress because i don't think i've
seen anything
you didn't see the the the whole trial
i don't know she uses that character oh
[ __ ] that's that was a good line that's
an underrated line actually thanks have
you seen anything she's in like and
really like watched it it's aquaman i
saw aquaman and it's terrible it's
absolutely like as soon as she started
talking i was like did she ruin the
movie for you wow yeah and this is well
before any of that that i saw i didn't
know anything about this and i was like
who is that how did they get hired there
are now over three million signatures on
a petition to get her out of aquaman too
i hope so because i'm not watching it
with her in it you're not to watch the
aquaman 2. you're telling me aquaman one
of the greatest movies ever made you're
not going to watch the sequel of it
because amber heard
i'll buy a ticket how's it i'll buy a
ticket i just won't that's fine
it's not jason momoa's fault that amber
is a man beater how did you just watch
pieces of aquaman it was probably like
on the like a flight and i'm like oh
i've never seen this before and then i
watched it and then it was like he
sleeps he's like i need to leave or
whatever and then you see like jason
mama like dive into the water i'm like
oh this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
because you did anything aquatic
oh this one has a [ __ ] like a flannel
on yeah any like [ __ ] work boots and
he dies into the water and he's in some
[ __ ] like shiny ass wetsuit or
something
everywhere from hell's angels to little
mermaid and [ __ ] i'm like i didn't watch
them that's the problem look i'm a fan
unfortunately of a lot of comic book
stuff
they tried to make aquaman so badass
that it's like try hardy teenage [ __ ] to
me and it's like it's like hot topic
teenager yeah yeah yeah it was very 90s
like they even did the slow zoom
oh so many like 90s slow zoom if you
watch it it's it's filmed like a 90s is
it intentionally supposed to i think it
was intentionally supposed to be comedic
in that sense
comedic i think so i don't know
i felt kind of kind of felt kind of
cheesy comedic it's supposed to be like
sort of you know what was really good
about this uh whole trial though is
because i think um he tried in england
to do this earlier to do the trial over
there there was another trial that
didn't really but the the thing is they
wanted it televised or they wanted live
right because
um the thing is it's it's all about like
getting his reputation back yeah it's
public opinion yeah because after her
[ __ ] expose like you know johnny depp
was like oh you [ __ ] woman beat her
everything and i don't know what to say
i was just like i don't know what's
going on in that relationship and i'm
like i won't be seeing pirates of the
caribbean anymore and it makes me sad
but oh well three movies to go but hey
that's fine
but no but yeah but then that that's the
thing though is that we needed
um
i think we needed an inside look into
like the the the nitty-gritty of what
was really going on because like
he never really got to say his part and
then everyone just [ __ ] canceled him
right right off of just what she said
and i was like dude that's [ __ ] crazy
it's it's the girl who cried wolf well
it was also very everything it was also
a very unique time yes the me too
movement
yeah so and then she took advantage of
it yeah that sucks too because it's
never news that somebody who is accused
of a crime like that gets exonerated
it's never going that's true it could
have happened like the case could have
been finished and then the news is out
oh actually he was innocent it's not
something
you don't get to cook for that
remember is the cancellation doesn't
sell papes no it doesn't
i can't get an advertiser on this
this is the exception to that rule yeah
because i feel like everybody is here
people get to you know be their nosy
selves and then see all the details and
then
brewing yeah that's way more news like i
feel like
i don't care about like celebrity news
as much i mean i feel like you guys are
a similar way but for some reason this
can't look away stop i can't stop
watching i watch all of it it's because
this kind of thing happens to regular
people every day too you know
yeah that's not exciting or fun this is
fun
uh no but okay we were talking about
this earlier so like amber um on the
tapes the tapes are super fascinating
because it's just that yeah and it's
like amber on the tapes is like i didn't
punch you
i hit you stop being a baby johnny
oh man the scariest line is go ahead and
tell them no one will believe that
that's [ __ ] terrifying and then she
went out with the article anyway it's
terrifying because it's [ __ ] true
dude yeah yeah
i mean if he did come out with it no one
would have been like yeah right she's
[ __ ] abusing you her yeah like even i
would have been like man you're a [ __ ]
dude the only time you can tell that
like the only time that would you could
fight against that is if you caught the
person saying it which they did they did
this is a miracle frankly a [ __ ]
miracle it is but how did they get these
tapes like he would have he would record
it yeah he would record it and then he
was like i need ammo now if you don't
have someone's permission to record i
thought like the laws against over the
phone oh so in real life i guess you can
i think in real life he's wearing a wire
or or was it off if he's like you know
home camera or something thing that you
can do with your phone your iphone
if you do a drop down on the menu
there's like an ear thing right there
whoa if you i don't have that you can
add it you have to add it but it looks
like that it's in the settings yeah it
looks like that yeah basically you can
hit that leave your phone somewhere no
no you you leave your phone somewhere
you put on your airpods and you can
listen to what it's hearing forever it's
a hearing device i don't got ears on
mine but you have to put it in you have
to go into your settings and then find
the hearing but it doesn't record it
just like gives you i don't know if it
records i'm sure you can also record
that means it'll take about 18 weeks to
do it so just just forget it that will
happen it won't happen
but it's just so crazy and wild that i
can do it you're telling me i could put
ear pods on right
put on my ear what am i taking a [ __ ]
i could hear her how long did it take
you to take your luna bar it took you
[ __ ] 22 months
i waited for a lucky day
watch this we're gonna watch this i
already showed the boys this but i want
to show the audiences
okay we're watching together here we go
yeah uh this is so this is amber heard
this is during um testimony this is
today so whenever you watch this
you guys tell me what you think's going
on i want to tell you what's going on
that looks like she snorted some coke
that's allergies
you guys
you guys think about what's going on i
won't tell you that looks like she's
doing coke who does this what does why
who goes like this
bolo young does that
so this is maybe the best thing and the
worst thing about the internet
is like
she could just be blowing her [ __ ]
nose into a napkin oh my nose that way
she didn't blow out she definitely went
and that was it but also why don't you
just do the words when you pull your
nose
that shows how comfortable she is like
dancing on the line you know yeah i
think so because that's a personality
disorder isn't it i think she's just so
used to crazy well just like stepping on
the line like that like she knows that
there's cameras everywhere she's [ __ ]
on the testimony stand you know and for
the like to do that is so crazy who
would do that i don't know maybe i'm
crazy who knows i feel crazy but i don't
know because
so for a long time we all were like well
maybe johnny's all [ __ ] up right but
then now i think that johnny's team is
so good they're very good that maybe
we're all like oh amber's all the way
[ __ ] up but maybe two things two
things two things can be true but ever
amber herself is better it seems like
they don't have any evidence she fired
her pr team by the way yeah she fired
them because they had bad headlines but
it's like it's kind of hard to make you
look good at this point you took a
dookie in the [ __ ] bed but it was a
practical joke johnny literally
it was a joke to the admission right
yeah she lied that she didn't know what
what the [ __ ] that was for so long and
then was like okay i [ __ ] do not
yeah they try to say what the dog did it
right but it was like human
and had corn in it
she cut it off quick though dude it
wasn't even it didn't even look that big
for a human no it didn't you could see
traces of fiber one
oh yeah that's a little bit oh look up
amber turd on twitter
[Music]
oh no story reasons paper turned so good
i didn't think of that one that's good
hashtag amber turd that's what it says
i didn't come up with it oh okay you're
just what part of the troll you guys on
right now right now i just uh finished
the the the psychologist
don't spoil it for me i'm barely there
the good psychologist or the bad
whatever you want that's america she's
so good yeah she's really amber her
psychologist is ridiculous bro so good
incorrect two court rooms huh like she
seems like she's like in familiar
territory whatever you said not quite
she's like a home court speaker it's
like no you're in she was schooling the
[ __ ] lawyer yeah she's like so you're
not board certified and she's like well
i've been doing this for years huge
highlight the stuff of the guy who's
self-judged he objected himself
oh sorry objection oh objection here say
whoops
[Laughter]
you